et elle rappelle alors donc du ministre
de l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
mais sur le terrain des enseignants
refusent t'il vraiment d'adhérer aux
valeurs de la république et de les
transmettre à leurs élèves ou la menace
est elle aujourd'hui tels que certains
professeurs ont décidé de baisser les
bras notamment sur les questions de
laïcité vous êtes invité à réagir sur le
conte télégramme daté france on vous
pose cette question transmettent les
valeurs de la république réalité ou
utopie place à notre débat tout de suite
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler gamal à bina
cofondateur du mouvement des droits
civiques bonsoir gamma d'amis d'un merci
d'être avec nous guillaume baissière
professeur d'histoire soutien d'eric
zemmour merci d'être avec nous une
petite mise au point tout d'abord
aujourd'hui du ministre de l'éducation
nationale plutôt bienvenue ou plutôt
maladroit gamme alabina je peux dire ce
que je pense d'eux des maladresses qui
sont succédé au gouvernement mais
l'effectif est assez maladroit ce qui
donne le sentiment qui est des
professeurs seraient pas enclins à
vouloir des valeurs dans les pluies qui
sont je rappelle tout de même un petit
peu obligatoire aujourd'hui avec droits
civiques donc l'éducation civique plus
tôt je pense que c'est un petit peu
léger c'est des rappels qui vont pas
bien mais en vérité alors vous vous êtes
justement le disait professeur s'est
politisée puisque soutien d'eric zemmour
mais tout de même professeur quand vous
entendez le ministre vous interpeller
vous rappelle qu'il faut rappeler ses
valeurs de la république comment vous
réagissez alors tout d'abord je suis
professeur mais pas politisée quand je
suis professeur je ne fais pas de
politique a versé c'est bien le préciser
tout comme quand on est jeune et ça ne
fait pas de politique normalement
c'est bien c'est ça je vais même le
contraire j'essaie de pousser les élèves
à réfléchir alors je suis très surpris
en effet de cette déclaration de
jean-michel blanquer qui va selon m'a
vraiment à rebours de ce qui se passe
dans le réel les professeurs sont plutôt
victimes on vient de voir deux
professeurs qui ont été la cible
justement de finalement de menaces de
mort donc je ne comprends pas pourquoi
jean michel blanquer a choisi de
peut-être victimiser les bourreaux je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas de de traiter
les victimes que sont les professeurs
pour l'instant
comme s'ils étaient suspects de ne pas
transmettre les valeurs de la république
ça veut dire quoi qui est un procès
d'intention à l'égard des les
professeurs vous estimez de la première
mine de l'éducation là je réagisse
vraiment l'avoir analysée mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi il a fait cette
sortie aujourd'hui alors premier message
d'un atelier sur les réseaux sociaux
télégramme il faut protéger nos
professeurs les vrais garants de la
transmission des valeurs républicaines
gamme el abida ce sont les vrais garants
de la transmission des valeurs
républicaines est ce qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de choses qui pèse sur les
épaules des professeurs dans un contexte
parfois tendue est ce que c'est vraiment
leur rôle à le et de manière exclusive
c'est intéressant que les professeurs
sont sur le plateau aussi bien bien
évidemment la question et morgane par la
mais non je pense que on leur
fait peser beaucoup trop de choses sur
les épaules pour deux raisons la
première parce que c'est pas leur rôle
clairement les valeurs dont on parle de
la république s'est pas c'est pas à
l'école de les transmettre c'est pas
j'ai été choquée moi pour l'éducation
civique j'ai pas compris que si j'ai pas
connu ça quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai
eu et j'ai échappé à ce genre de
plaisanterie on a fait du droit mais
très tard évidemment mais en aucun cas
de l'éducation civique ne veut rien dire
on veut transmettre des valeurs qui sont
des valeurs partagées par tous deux fait
puisqu'on est citoyen de droits et de
devoirs mais ces valeurs là davantage
besoin aujourd'hui
je suis pas certaines salles point c'est
que les questions de laïcité qui sont
posées sont des questions qui sont liées
à l'exclusion simplement quand on parle
de laïcité en règle générale on ne cible
pas les catholiques qui n'ont compris
avec la halle avec la batteuse à 95
écoles privées sous contrat c'est plus
la question qui se pose au risque de
voir les gens qui sont aussi de banlieue
dont on imagine t serait musulmans pour
la plupart d'entre eux serait une sorte
de cinquième colonne qui voudraient
imposer d'autres valeurs qui serait
l'alternative à l'appui que ça ça n'a
pas de sens dans la mesure où si vous
allez la rue petit par exemple dans le
10e arrondissement vous avez des tonnes
d'écoles juives qui ne pose aucun
problème et ne sont pas incompatibles
gratuit qu on respecte la loi ça fait on
ne va pas déborder sur le cadre légal
mais on est on n'impose pas ses règles
personnel à l'extérieur on sait à poser
soi-même donc c'est vrai que cette
question de mettre une charge ciel lourd
sur les professeurs pour leur demander
d'en signer valeur qu'une structure
ancienne pas à l'école abrite et
ailleurs ça c'est pas compréhensible
alors c'est vrai que il y à un contexte
particulier on a parlé de cet hommage à
samuel pâtit 98 incidents recensés
notamment cet homme qui est toujours en
garde à vue depuis lundi pour avoir
menacé de mort le personnel d'un collège
dans la drôme où son fils avait écopé
d'un avertissement après avoir crié
allahu akbhar lors d'un hommage de 2
samuel bâtisse n'est malheureusement pas
un cas isolé il ya aussi aujourd'hui
dans l'actualité ce couple menacé à
marseille photo de sa nouvelle patrie
elle a l'appuyons je le répète une
centaine d'incidents relevé qu'est ce
que ça dit guillaume baissière ça vous
évoque quoi ah non je tout d'abord je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec l'analyse
de monsieur abina au sujet du fait que
les professeurs ou leur demande trop un
moulin dans l'éducation et l'éducation
c'est l'heureux de la famille donc
peut-être qu'il a eu une faillite à sun
à ce niveau là est ce que m'évoque ces
symptômes donc ces voix-là 98 d'une
petite centaine de cas d'incident relevé
qu'on s'en sert de recenser exactement
eh bien ça me pour moi ce sont des
symptômes que que la france n'est pas
apaisée et que souvent on peut entendre
dire que eric zemmour lui essaye de
mener une guerre ou de créer une guerre
mais finalement il ya déjà un conflit il
est là lui met des mots sur les maux il
constate ce conflit et ils l'expliquent
il veut en chercher les causes le
diagnostic propos pour proposer une
solution alors qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas c'est tout à fait légitime d'en
débattre mais lui dit il y à un symptôme
est donc pour moi ces manifestations le
manifeste son
l'exemple est rassurant tout gamin la
mine à votre avis là-dessus sans une
centaine d'incidents cas isolé ou ouvrez
monde la société comme un ensemble de
penser chez eric zemmour laurie les maux
de la société s'exprime par une chose
claire c'est un caractère le caractère
de l'exclusion des gens qui vivent en
banlieue en règle générale alors il ya
toujours des petits voyous des peas abc
les provocateurs zetes d'affaires du
monde qui a prouvé qu'il professeur et
qui crient allah ouakbar on sent bien
que c'est geronimo qui parle ça ne veut
rien dire félicité par son père qui lui
valait d'être un locateur ses
provocations bête parce qu'ils n'ont pas
mesuré la gravité de l'assassinât de cet
homme des renforts appelés quand même
une femme a été décapitée ya encore
quelques jours 77 ans avec ce professeur
des écoles est la même qui a fait ça est
à même de l'extrême droite bon
apparemment matin il a des premiers
mémoire et tout oublié mais quoi qu'il
en soit et c'est le même constat que je
fais la barbarie et la barbarie alors
maintenant on cherche un sous jacent
religieux qui aurait une sorte de
réflexion antérieures ou qui sera
organisée je tiens à dire une chose ce
soir parce que là vous parlez vous poser
de très sympathique qu'un point mais m
mais vous avez rejoint un homme qui
n'est pas malheureusement et qui a des
gros problèmes d'analystes qui n'a pas
le courage de venir parler à des gens
dont il parle tout le temps je parle des
gens comme nous moi je suis prêt à
l'attendre sur n'importe quel débat et à
ce moment là on verra qui en plus sont
prises routeur le prêt de monsieur
zemmour c'est qu'il parle de
problématiques qui sont des cas isolés
des cas marginaux et qu'il met des
problématiques en avant qui reste
problématique marginal évidemment que
c'est choquant qu'un homme se fasse
décapité et ça on discute même pas là
dessus moi j'ai l'amour des livres dont
je n'accepte pas qu'on me l'avait
violentée l'homme qui est là pour donner
la connaissance en revanche lorsque la
france est en train de sombrer avec une
dette abyssale lorsqu'il ya des
problèmes par rapport aux convictions
tués quand des centaines de milliers
personnes dont des familles endeuillées
lorsqu'on à l'incapacité chronique de
sortir ce pays du marasme dans lequel il
s'est enfoncé avec la
désindustrialisation et il en parle moi
ce qu'il reproche à monsieur zemmour
c'est quoi c'est qui ne donne pas de
réponse sa réponse est systématique
c'est la problématique c'est les
banlieues la problématique c'est la
question vous avez qu'elle soit
familiale ce qui est une c'est à la
marge tout ça est aujourd'hui s'il a le
courage d'affronter les gens dont il
parle tout le temps il ne fait pas de
moi je pense qu'il est courageux
j'espère pour lui si la ce courage à ce
moment là j'attends quand il veut et on
pourra débattre mais on pourra débattre
de vraies questions qui n'abordent
jamais parce qu'il est pas en mesure de
répondre aux questions économiques il ne
sait pas faire
c'est un homme qui veut briguer la
magistrature suprême et qui vous parle
d'incidents marginaux je suis désolé
aujourd'hui les gels et je ne parlais
pas des banlieues j'ai jaune ils ont
peur par rapport à ce qu'ils mettent
dans leur assiette donc c'est en ça que
je dis c'est 98 cas recensés qui arrive
évidemment reste des cadres soit de
provocation avait s'il est folle et
condamné choix des gens qui sont des
totaux ratés qui ont raté leur vie
qu'ils n'ont rien à perdre et quand on
n'a rien à perdre fait de graves fautes
des bêtises ou des meurtres en
l'occurrence et c'est ça qu'on doit
poser comme question quel est le vrai
problème est ce que le problème est lié
à une sorte de nature c'est inhérent à
la nature de ces gens ou est ce que
c'est un problème de fabrication de
montres la fabrique de monstres en
france je vais annoncer juste un truc
très rapidement on n'y a pas de baboo
schiste en france et on espère qu'il n'y
aura pas de zemmouri ce temps
aujourd'hui on a des zones qui sont
exclus et ces gens explique ne rêve que
de vivre dans d'autres quartiers tous
autant qu'ils sont alors on va vous
laisser répondre on fait un petit détour
par ce message et puis non dans vos
propos la laïcité en tout cas selon
captifs qui nous écrit est bafouée elle
qui protège nos valeurs républicaines et
notre devise de fraternité si je vous
comprends bien il ya malavida il n'y a
pas de problème de deux rangées de la
laïcité priori en tout cas pas de
problème ancré sur ce thème en france
votre réponse aux lions baissière là il
y aura d accord sur le constat parce que
je pense que ce ne sont pas des cas
marginaux je vois que c'est endémique
avec les chiffres de nos sécurités vous
votre expérience de professeur
expérimenté
alors mon expérience de professeur à la
cancer quand j'étais en lycée
professionnel les menaces de mort que
j'ai eue c'était alors évidemment oui
oui alors mais pour moi c'était
tellement ben voila c'était finalement
non ce n'était pas normal j'étais choqué
mais je n'avais pas de victimiser on n'a
pas fait de tribunes de choses comme ça
enfin c'est pas la manière dont je
conçois la vie
décapité entre temps alors peut-être on
a tendance à vouloir se protéger en
médiatisant peut-être en tout cas
ce crime il y en avait
non c'était c'était avant c'était avant
donc voilà un jeune qui me menace quel
geste de l'égorgement et qui me dit mort
aux mécréants et un autre un moment
qu'ils vivent et voilà sur le coran g de
fumer dehors
enfin avec d'autres expressions
voilà donc pour moi et alors je n'aime
pas trop qu'on parle de la vie
personnelle parce que finalement aussi
quelqu'un n'a pas
[Musique]
éteint c'est un mal qui existe vraiment
comment vous analysé ce genre justement
de devenir une provocation comme le dit
gamme à la villa ou un mal effectivement
plus profonde de notre société on bafoue
justement la laïcité alors je crois que
c'est un mal plus profond de la société
mais pas parce que j'étais concerné je
crois que c'est trop facile de ne
s'intéresser à des sujets sociétaux que
lorsqu'on lévis
c'est pour ça qu'à une frange de la
population française qui dit y'a pas de
soucis d'immigration tout simplement
parce qu'ils se payent la sécurité
c'est à dire que quand on paye d'aider
des appartements à 12000 euros du mètre
carré l'île de jolo l'antique avec moi
là qui sont aussi donc il n'ya pas de
souci a pas de souci mais c'est facile
c'est sûr quand on est dans ces eaux là
de dire il n'ya pas de problème entre
turcs et les communes je dis ça et ils
vivent pas dans le quartier à
l'économiste oui mais justement le vote
communiste qui était plutôt populaire
une époque est passé alors j'ai pas dire
l'extrême droite mais passé au front
national et c'est pour ça que maintenant
l'électorat de la gauche finalement
c'est de moins en moins le peuple et
qu'il ya cette volonté c'est pour ça
qu'on parle de ça nos gauchistes qui est
un mot bon un peu fourre-tout peut-être
vous voilà je comprends que ça fasse à
se faire un peu trop ridicule c'est
juste ridicule je ne pense pas en
revanche c'est importer des électeurs sa
selle c'est déjà fait on a pu penser aux
états unis et c'est exactement la
stratégie de certains partis politiques
et d'une mentalité gauchistes
j'aurai pour l'aca
là pour ça gauchy de ces concepts
abscons qui veut rien dire qui veut dire
que des gens de gauche ou d'extrême
gauche ont rejeté par la gauche
l'extrême gauche serait plutôt favorable
est courant aux musulmans mais c'est pas
ce qui se passe l'extrême gauche voit
bien avec mélenchon una discours qui est
double à la fois il est contrôle
religieux de fait il c'est une fois et
en même temps de l'autre côté et leur
envie d'avoir un vote qu'on va appeler
communautaire pour dire je suis pas le
pire je vais vous aider je vais calmer
les choses on a été les slams au
gauchisme c'est de dire que des gens
d'extrême gauche sera en soutien à des
islamistes ça qui est grave c'est pour
ça que je dise que ce terme ne veut rien
dire c'est un thème qui est abscons et
qui est surtout disqualifiant en vérité
les gens d'extrême gauche ne sont pas du
tout très peu croyants et pas du tout
favorable et cora comment courants
radicaux islamistes ou ski islamistes si
on situe sur l'échiquier politique c'est
plutôt à droite c'est le conservatisme
donc en cela c'est cette idée d' islamo
gauchistes c'est façon disqualifié y
aurait d'autres termes qui est utilisée
aussi l'indigénisme alors cela c'est
pour disqualifier les gens qui sont de
gauche mais qui sont contre le
néocolonialisme ou le code de
l'indigénat concours produirait dans les
banlieues c'est une façon chaque mois de
dire à des gens qui sont racisées le
terme est valable à dessus ces records
autour maths et on sait que je passe ici
pour dire vous n'avez pas voilà parole
vous ne devez pas parlé parce que vous
êtes un indigéniste donc le saas et les
méthodes souvent qui viennent d'extrême
droite pour disqualifier la personne qui
vous utilisez un terme qui n'est pas les
français se victimise le verbe victime
s'est pas victimiser texte parle
d'accord face à terme pour la récupérer
les états unis victimisation ça n'existe
pas en france donc quelqu'un car une
posture victimaire agace l'a d'abord
n'est pas les victimes il ya une réalité
sociale qui lisse en france il ya une
exclusion qui manifestent il ya un
mécanisme des décideurs je parle pas la
population française qui n'est pas
concerné les décideurs qui font en sorte
qu'on reste en branle et je pose une
question devait très simple quand
j'hésite à leur légende dans l'ue et
veut partir de deux mauvais quartier
c'est normal comme tout le monde sur la
plus large en battant même un peu
meilleure mais comment se fait-il qu'ils
ont été concentrées là dans monsieur
zemmour prétend qu'il y aurait une
fabrication du colonisation de musulmans
je répondais chez zemmour que si on
avait le pouvoir sur les commissions
d'attribution de hln il ya longtemps
qu'on serait dans le xvième donc c'est
un mensonge
malheureusement il manipule beaucoup les
chiffres continuent par an qu'il y avait
80 % de musulmans dans les prisons il
s'est ravisé parce qu'elles ont qu'elle
comptait mener ces 2 25% j'allais dire à
ce monsieur zemmour qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est 75 % d'européens derrag ans donc
c'est en ça je vous dis le problème qui
se pose c'est qu'il a une analyse de
choses qui est fausse ils vous parlent
de montrer qu'il a connu il ya 40 ans
c'est un canton pratiquement dans une
situation qui a évolué et qui a
gravement dégénéré c'est ça qui se pose
aujourd'hui s'cusez moi pour le regard
non mais le mot de la fin
je comprends tout à fait mais si on
importe les banlieues dans le 16e et
bien le 16e deviendra montreuil et vous
dites que l'islamo gauchisme et abscons
et je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
stupide de la part du gauchisme qui a
été très les garanties chrétiens et pour
mettre l'église à sa place pendant
longtemps de pactiser avec l'islamisme
qui finalement on les appelle les idiots
utiles alors tout le monde est l'idiot
utile quel est exactement mais il n'a
pas tort tout le temps et bien ce sont
des idiots utiles parce que quand ce
sera trop tard et bien finalement leur
rêve d'élection ce sera sur un chaos
total
nous voulons éviter ça je suis vraiment
aimer la france c'est là où je vais vous
dire votre erreur c'est pour vous a dit
ça quand vous rejoignez un monsieur est
immense et qu'il a été éduqué par un
alain soral le mythe de la guerre civile
qui est une obsession qui est une
véritable obsession fosse se constitue
par des peurs qui sont immatérielles la
guerre civile si vous la regardez
regardez bien les statistiques et rim
vous êtes pour des gis l'agression par
journée ces céréales c'est la
délinquance non c'est pas de brider
recoules gorge à l'époque c'était pire
d'accord n'ont pas pas autant apprécié
mais si vous êtes pro d'histoire c'est
très mec legacy vite sont là les joueurs
de l'extérieur il faut deux factions
intérieur avec deux idéologies
aujourd'hui il ya pas de soutien ces
gens-là ans par les musulmans de
banlieue n'ont aucun soutien ni les pays
d'origine de personnes il ya quelques il
ya quelques loups blancs et les calculs
enfin ou blanc il ya quelques loup
solitaire plutôt qu'ils vont commettre
des actions violentes dont ils savent
parfaitement qu'ils vont être abattus
derrière et le savent donc cédé
suicidaire 50 ans c'est violent est
gratuit mais ça ne mène nulle part il
n'y a pas vraiment de vraie idéologie ce
qui intègre être contacté pour lui
il ya quand même disons annexe avait les
cheveux le wahhabisme j'ai un peu
étudiée et c'est intéressant donc pas
d'idéologie c'est en posture une feuille
mais en tout cas les élèves qui qui crée
enfin vous à la voix de bao qui s'amuse
à le cacher la noblesse et la
provocation oui mais ce sont eux et pour
eux ça rejoint quand même une nébuleuse
alors si vous voulez pas laisser
l'idéologie ça rejoint un fantasme
islamiste qui correspond peut-être à une
société à une frange de la société en
paupérisation mais on n'a pas ça dans le
cantal à y évoluer dans la halle aux
années c'est le très pop a fait
l'histoire c'est un peu long mais en
substance
j'ai fait pas tellement c'est un long
débat mais ce que vous appelez islamisme
c'est un courant idéologique qui vient
d'arabie effectivement et qu'il perde à
l'ablation les d'accord le brest pour
mélange islamisme d'arabie et des frères
musulmans mélange tout comprend rien à
rien il ya un islamisme complètement
déstructuré qui est le seul où habitent
comme la paix d'accord pour la paix les
djihadistes et à l'islamisme structuré
qui est frères musulmans qui est plutôt
légaliste et eux il mélange des deux il
veut me dire que le coupeur gorge ses
frères musulmans mais c'est pas vrai
c'est très complexe il faut en parler
avec un peu plus de d'apaisement et de
temps avec trois heures la prochaine
fois merci en tout cas tous les deux
liés ou baissière gamal habillés d'un
d'avoir été avec nous